cain voit ce que vous paraissez peu
comprennent ce que vous êtes ces mots
empruntés au prince de machiavel
pourrait résumer la doctrine des manuels
macron qui par ailleurs a consacré un
mémoire de philosophie à cet ouvrage
incontournable de la philosophie
politique mais derrière ce qu'il paraît
ce nouveau président le plus jeune de la
vème république et de l'histoire des
démocraties occidentales
jamais élue au parcours inédit qui se
dit ni de droite ni de gauche
alors de quoi le maquereau nisme est il
le nom pour en débattre j'ai le plaisir
de recevoir deux invités prestigieux
alain badiou bonjour vous êtes
philosophe romancier dramaturge vous
êtes un intellectuel qu'on dit engagé à
gauche très à gauche
vous êtes pour réinventer le communisme
c'est bien ça y est vous essayez ben
écoutez vous allez nous en parler vous
avez dispensés votre dernier séminaire
le 16 janvier dernier au théâtre de la
commune à aubervilliers à la veille de
vos 80 ans et nous attendons donc pour
fait était votre dernier ouvrage
l'immanence des vérités bienvenus en
face de vous olivier mangin bonjour un
bon jeu dont vous êtes écrivain
essayiste éditeur vous avez été
directeur de la revue esprit de 1988 à
décembre 2012 vous avez fait vous même
la connaissance des manuels macron il y
a vingt ans alors qu'il avait 20 ans et
vous lui avez donc proposé de rejoindre
le comité de rédaction de la revue qu'il
a quitté donc en décembre 2016 lorsqu'il
s'est donc présenté à la présidence de
la république messieurs peut-être votre
réaction sur ce film qui se veut donc un
peu la chronique d'une victoire annoncée
pour son réalisateur
quelle est votre lecture de cette
campagne kaka kaka fait emmanuel macron
olivier mongin bat bruno de les
anticiper la victoire moi je connais
bien manu le malin je dois dire qu'il ya
un an je voyais tous les obstacles
toutes les difficultés je n'aurais
jamais parié au sens strict sur une
victoire dont il ya eu les opportunités
qu'on connaît mais on voit très bien on
va y revenir tout à l'heure qui est une
capacité très rapide politique
d'intervention de sa part et de
construction d'une institution qui est
tout à fait étonnant mais moi je
voyez pas comment vous pouvez enlever
les obstacles pour présenter sarkozy
fillon le ps hollande voit bon et à
l'époque on prézégat this may cry je
dégageais à bercy sur sa gauche
est ce qu'on doit y est pas non plus
c'est l'ouverture à droite aussi forte
mais voilà bon donc je dis bravo à ce
qu'avait anticipé et moi le connaissant
bien mais je reviendrai par contre parce
que je pense qu'il faut comprendre on
verra si on peut parler d'un maquereau
nisme philosophique feu veut que je ne
crois pas mais je pense que macron c'est
un animal politique au sens d'aristote
c'est une bête politique et donc moi je
dis je n'ai pas prévu ce qui était
prévisible pour monsieur de l'est mais
en même temps je pense qu'il faut
remonter son parcours justement durant
20 ans terre qu'elle voir quel est
l'accord dieu le sait qui l'a conduit à
croire à ses toiles on va en parler il
ya un parcours qui permet de comprendre
la décision
alain badiou écoutez moi je proposerai
pour décrire cette affaire macron
l'expression paradoxal de coup d'état
démocratique
oui et coup d'état démocratique gc la
bio justifié dans la discussion
ça suppose naturellement la personnalité
nécessaire pour que ce que d'état ait
lieu
ça suppose beaucoup de facteurs
différencier mais évidemment il ya
toujours dans le coup d'état
démocratique dans le coup d'état en
général un élément de surprise c'est à
dire s'il était totalement prévisible
s'il était totalement il serait inscrit
dans l'état des choses
le fait que ce soit un coucou réussir
des circonstances fait que les
spectateurs à différents degrés de
développement de ce coût peuvent être
plus ou moins surpris il comprend très
bien que il y a un certain temps il
était très peu probable que ce qu'on
réussisse mais c'était un coup et le
film montre bien que sa préparation et
systématique est extrêmement attentive
et alain badiou quand vous parlez de
coup d'état alors il ya déjà une forme
de violence en fait dans l' usage de ce
terme
mais c'est un coup politique ou c'est
véritablement un coup d'état
je pense que c'est un coup d'état dans
la mesure où le coeur de la question il
veut s'emparer du pouvoir d'état c'est
en ce sens que je parle de coup d'état
naturellement fondamentalement c'est un
processus politique
c'est un processus politique mais qui a
une cible très déterminé et qui
profitent de circonstance qui sont en
réalité des circonstances de
désagrégation partielle du fondement
normal de l'institution étatique c'est à
dire que c'est karl et les structures
politiques autour de lui que ce soit le
parti socialiste les républicains d'un
côté ont échoué dans leur rendez vous en
faites avec leurs électeurs et dans
cette déception qu'ont à arriver en fait
à ce concours de circonstances
absolument et ce concours de
circonstances il faut y ajouter aussi
parce que ça a été tout de même
extraordinairement utiliser la menace en
quelque sorte dans la coulisse de
l'extrême droite
ça a été quand même un thème majeur de
la propagande en particulier au second
tour
olivier mongin vous êtes non gens
principalement au coup d'état ce que je
pense qu'on est quand même encore en
démocratie je ne vois pas en quoi les
décisions de maquereaux n'ont pas
accompagné le processus démocratique
mais oui mais oui échos d'état mais moi
je n'emploie pas le mot coup d'état qui
est quand même très marqué c'est votre
paradoxe vous l'avez dit saint pardoux
moi je dirais de choses quand même d'une
part macron il intervient dans un
contexte un petit peu de de désarroi et
de dilution de deux partis traditionnels
donc la vraie question elle est là ni
droite ni gauche on peut discuter de ce
à l'infini
on a assisté là à la disparition de deux
partis classiques
est-ce que macro recrée un type de parti
nouveau où est ce qu'on va recréer un
parti classique avec des gens qui sont
plus du côté de l'entreprise que de la
gauche classique ou de la droite
classique donc
d'une part on à la désagrégation d'un
système qui existe depuis 45
et c'est pas pour rien que les débats
vont tout de suite se focaliser sur la
sécurité sociale sur le problème du
droit du travail etc ceci sur les acquis
de la résistance et un système est très
institué ce système il ne tient plus
alors on a changé de monde ça c'est un
autre débat qui le débat sur la
mondialisation
reste qu est ce qu ils gardent quand
même du gaullisme c'est peut-être les
ans sans cela vous parlez comme
mitterrand coup d'état démocratique
égard peut-être du gaullisme ce que de
gaulle avait constitué c'est à dire une
constitution très présidentialiste donc
on à la désagrégation d'un d'une espèce
d'institutions au sein de l'état je suis
entièrement d'accord
de l'autre côté on a quelqu'un qui
accompagnent effectivement
ce que j'appellerais le présidentialisme
rosanvallon et d'autres aujourd'hui qui
travaille sur la démocratie
je n'arrête pas de dire qu'aujourd'hui
le régime politique présidentialiste et
celui qui occupe le terrain partout
partout et en janvier on le voit alors
simplement je m'arrête sur un point on y
reviendra peut-être aussi les bifaces et
ça c'est peut-être le paradoxe pour bien
comprendre emmanuel macron choix il faut
comprendre qu'il doit au départ en 2002
je crois qu'ils votent pour chevènement
donc c'est c1 et à part quand il arrive
à la revue esprit qui voit rigueur il
est plutôt chez rocard donc macro cette
deuxième gauche c'est l'état et la
société civile donc aussi quand on dit
qu'il fait un coup d'état
on ne peut penser ce qu'on veut dans
marche il y a quand même tout un
discours sur la société civile qu'on va
dire entrepreneuriale tout ce que vous
voulez mais il ya quand même quelque
chose de démocratique en tout cas dans
cette capacité est d'ailleurs de former
un mouvement
maintenant qu'elle est effectivement les
communistes c'est sympa rires alain
badiou une deuxième gauche matinée de
chevènementisme de souverainisme est ce
que ça vous paraît être une bonne
définition du maquereau nisme si tout
face la définition de la politique
proprement dit du mas grenier est encore
un peu incertaine puisque il a construit
son aventure dans une ambiguïté
concernant ce point mais ce que ce que
je voudrais dire par rapport à ce que
est ce que vous avez dit ce que le mot
coup d'état ne contient pas par lui même
quelque chose dont il démocratique pour
ça que j'ai ajouté les mocratique
discuter parce que tout de même un
élément très frappant des coups d'état
c'est que tout se concentre à un moment
donné dans le pouvoir d'état et le
pouvoir d'état définit les paramètres
qui vont être ceux de son propre règne
et là nous avons quand même quelque
chose d'extraordinaire d'habitude
c'était tout de même les partis qui
décident est qu'ils allaient être
président la cellule incident qui a
désigné le parti
le président a été nommé individu par
individu dont le parti a été construit
individu par individu par le par le
président sur ces vélos par l'est
effectivement de cette figure
autoritaire et je rappelle que napoléon
iii un ancêtre du coup d'état s'est fait
élire en partie sur le mot d'ordre de
restitution du suffrage universel donc
cette donnée à la fois populiste et
nationales en quelque sorte je la
retrouve chez makro ou le thème de
l'unité se conjugue avec le thème de la
nouveauté
voilà unités nouveautés appropriation au
monde moderne changement ce sont les
thèmes généraux de la politique de
maquereaux moi je ne dirais pas
populiste c'est quand même au stade où
nous sommes c'est pas nécessairement un
avis que tout le monde peut partager
on peut avoir l'impression que ce cas
était là le populisme je parle surtout
de celui d'extrême droite est quand même
un petit peu faibli grâce à mâcon macron
qu'ils soient affaiblis mais il n'est
pas pour autant
c'est nous le débat de savoir si macron
ce qu'il peut faire le problème il est
l'action mais je prends part préféré ce
que j'entends pas nécessairement la
dimension je ne prends que sortent des
médias tient dans leurs prix mais on
avait quand même et encore deux mois une
grille de lecture qui était purement
identitarisme c'est à dire c'était
l'unité l'immigration vous êtes
suffisamment intervenue ces questions
pour qu'il y ait besoin d'assister on
était complètement focalisé là dessus on
était chez moi je fais partie des champs
mais on est inquiet de la montée de
marine le pen
quelque part macron coup d'état
démocratique ou pas coup d'état des
mines nous a provisoirement entre
guillemets je sors partie de cette
sordide ça alain badiou en remontant un
petit peu dans les archives on se rend
compte que jean lecanuet dans l époque
dans les années 60 qui parle est
effectivement déjà 2 alors ça s'appelle
la france en marche à l'époque un slogan
héros de la résistance aux hommes
politiques qui étaient conservateurs
plusieurs fois ministre sous des
gouvernements de droite défenseur du
centrisme
à l'époque il était aussi il se disait
jeune et moderne est-ce que là
finalement on nous revend pas un
emmanuel macron nouveau une forme de
bronze de centrisme revisité alors qu'au
fond c'est quelque chose que on a déjà
connu
oui ça à moi j'ai connu l'épisode lecanu
et je n'ai pas été le premier d'ailleurs
à remarquer une espèce de similitudes
comme ça explique entre la tentative de
le cas du ni droite ni gauche très
finale entre la compétence la société
civile l'unité et c'est tout ça était
déjà présent donc tout n'est pas de tout
nouveau tout beau dans la trajectoire de
macron il s'en faut de beaucoup et puis
surtout ce qui ce qui ce qui me frappe
c'est que là c'est ce que je disais tout
à l'heure c'est à dire le rapport entre
la détention du pouvoir et
l'organisation politique générale du
parti etc change de sens d'une certaine
manière avec lui et le maniement de la
constitution reprend un tour qui au fond
c'est un peu son tour d'origine aussi on
est un peu son tour d'origine
et ça c'est le côté qu'on pourrait dire
néo gaulliste en effet de macron
j'accepterai cela mais après tout de
gaulle on l'a un peu oublié il est aussi
arrivé au pouvoir par un coup d'état qui
lui n'était pas un coup d'état
pleinement démocratique pas l'armée joie
quand même un rôle relativement
déterminant et donc je pense que ces
mutations subite du champ politique
centré de façon exclusive il veut sur
une personne
interroge sur le contexte dans lequel
ont pu se produire ça qui m'intéresse
qu'est-ce qui a fait que quelque chose
comme macron était possible alors est ce
à dire que vous faites des similitudes
entre la france post guerre d'algérie et
celle d'aujourd'hui
oui c'était je ferai la similitude qui
est une sorte de fatigue évidente du
disposition une aile politique lobby n'a
donc à mon avis la clé a été il faut
bien le dire le le le dépérissement de
la gauche le facteur numéro un ce
quelque chose comme un déchet chemin qui
a conduit au congrès d'epinay 71
une absence de propositions véritables e
et la création d'un régime dans lequel
on peut d'autant plus urgent ir
quelqu'un qui dit je ne suis ni droite
ni gauche je suis gauche et droite et
c'est que en vérité la différence entre
les deux était devenu imperceptible très
largement voudrais terminer en reprenant
un point que vous
mis en avant à très juste titre le grand
problème de la france c'est la fin du
golo communisme
voilà et à la fin de ce qui a été mis en
place après la dernière guerre mondiale
ça je pense que c'est le problème
stratégique l'aubaine politiques
stratégiques innovants et d'être
uniquement économie j'avais écrit un
petit live sur de quoi sarkozy est-il le
nom dans lequel je disais que sarkozy
était à mes yeux la première figure qui
tentait avec ses moyens propres de dire
que en effet c'était fini du golo
communisme mais il était trop capricieux
incertain et voyous pour mener cette
tâche à bien il s'est discrédité
progressivement je pense en effet que
macron et tout lui sarkozy dans une
figure opposé à certains égards à celle
de sarkozy notamment sur les questions
identitaires exemple et puis une figure
aussi de bonnes élèves bons lecteurs
olivier mongin quand emplois de ses
voisins européens la figure d' emmanuel
macron fascine on parle en allemagne
gerhard schröder à la française
en angleterre c'est cette troisième voie
et tony blair qui s'est invité en france
côté italien c'est le nouveau matteo
renzi diriez-vous que on est dans cette
forme en fait de troisième voie de la
social démocratie avec emmanuel macron
il faut complètement revoir la grille de
lecture
non moi ça faut revoir les grilles de
lecture fait l'intérêt de ma croussette
voir s'il peut le proposer dans ça ça
pose quand même quelques éditions ce que
je pense dans la suite de ce qui vient
des dykes on vit un moment historique
qui n'est quand même pas celui de lecanu
a ni de sarkozy
aujourd'hui tous les français qu'ils
aient des mômes ou pas qu'ils aient
voyagé ou pas savent que la
mondialisation ça veut dire quelque
chose
le problème de mâcon va être très
pédagogique qui va l'être et ça c'est ce
que j'attends du discours présidentiel
c'est pas nécessairement le premier
ministre qu'il aura comment expliquer à
quelqu'un qui expliquent le monde dans
lequel on est qu'il n'est pas celui d'un
de cagnac est un moment historique
particulier qui est celui des arts dogan
de poutine qui est celui de train etc
est celui où le politique doit
réapprendre à je dirais contrôler
l'économie clé vous qui l'avez connu et
qu'il avait côtoyé donc pendant une
quinzaine d'années à la revue esprit qui
avait vu en fait sa trajectoire
intellectuelle et moi je les veux
pendant toutes ces zones effectivement
alors que qu'auriez-vous à dire quelle
est votre lecture en fait de cet homme
politique donc d'un nouveau genre est ce
qu'il faut parler en fait d'un
philosophe devenu président ou d'un
politique éclairée comment qui sortent
la rencontre écrit coeur était très
importante
certainement que marie-claude entendu
sans foi dire il faut d'abord apprendre
à argumenter ce qu'on essaie de faire là
un petit peu quel concept tu emploies
comment tu discutes je pense que macron
ça il a ça a du bon
moi je n'ai pas trop vu dans les
meetings des meetings apparemment il
faisait un peu des tunnels mais doit dès
que l'on voit dans un débat télévisuel
que c'était sa force et que marine le
pen
moi je dirais le philosophe il est là il
a une capacité d'argumentation comme on
apprend à l'école normale ou ailleurs
même s'il n'est pas rentré voilà ensuite
je pense que mâcon vous l'avez cité et
j'y reviens c'est une bête politique
dans trois lieux d'entrée de jeu il sait
qui veut faire de la politique
il le sait et la bêtise du ps de pas
avoir compris qu'il fallait lui donner
devenu banquier pour se donner les
moyens de faire de la politique
finalement ou baba sy les parents très
anormal je suis pas si vous voulez faire
lettres ou philo se jugeait trop su il
fait l'ena bon il fait l'ena il fait
l'europe il fait la commission attali il
connaît tous les grands patrons parce
qu'ils défilent dans la commission
attali et mon avis c'était un peu le
déclic il va passer par la banque
vous connaissez un homme est aujourd'hui
un grand fonctionnaire qui n'a pas fait
du privé du public
c'est dans ton fia s'était enduit ciment
et la privatisation régulier d'akron et
n'est pas une exception c'est un homme
qui sait prendre les opportunités mais
il sait aussi que garder le pouvoir
c'est plus difficile que de le conquérir
ça c'est la première chose de il sait
qu'on n'a pas le pouvoir si
effectivement on ne respecte pas le
peuple mais le problème de macron savez
d'entendre effectivement et de voir
jusqu'où tu peux aller ça va commencer
par le bien sûr le droit du travail et
c'est d'avoir une pédagogie d'avoir une
lecture du moment que nous vivons alors
mais ça alain badiou quand on entend ce
que dit olivier mongin comment est-ce
qu'on peut être à ce point en fait
proche du peuple être pédagogique
quand lui-même en fait 10 de sa
présidence qu'elle doit être
jupitérienne alors qu'il y ait déjà un
terme à ces à ses côtés qu'il se
qu'il se met un petit peu dans cette
lignée d'une présidence golo
mitterrandienne qui était quand même
complètement stratosphérique vis-à-vis
des citoyens gaullistes des pardons de
gaulle d'expliquer quand même des choses
de manière assez claire oui est ce que
je pense c'est que le problème que vous
soulevez est un problème insoluble
voilà ce que je pense mais c'est à dire
le peuple le fait est qu'aujourd'hui
pour l'essentiel l'économie mondialisée
il ya cent son niveau d'existence y
compris des firmes elle-même qui est
pour les plus grandes firmes sont toutes
multinationales et un président de
société est aussi à l'aise à shanghai
que que amicaux rio de janeiro à paris
par contre le contrôle politique des
peuples restent dans l'espace national
pour l'essentiel et il ne je ne crois
pas que à l'économie mondiale puisse
correspondre aujourd'hui quelque chose
qui ressemblerait un gouvernement
mondial par conséquent nous avons une
contradiction en véritable contradiction
véritable qu'est le nouveau de contrôle
nécessaire des populations dans un cadre
déterminé n'est pas adéquat au système
économique qui régente par ailleurs
largement la vie de cette société toute
la politique est prise dans cette
contradiction on voit très bien que l
essai d'opérer comme elle peut dans
l'espace de ce problème alors comme vous
le disiez finalement du point de vue des
logiques concurrentielles de la
mondialisation
il est très important de lancer des
grands programmes de privatisation de
mettre fin aux privilèges des
fonctionnaires nationaux etc etc
d'un autre côté pour obtenir un
assentiment minimum au contrôle de la
population
on peut pas faire ça avec une brutalité
sans frein on ne peut pas créer des
situations sociales absurde et c est je
pense donc nous irons d'une manière ou
d'une autre de crise en crise et
d'instabilité en instabilité macron
étant un des épisodes français
particulièrement français de cette
figure car je ne vois pas en état et
très rapidement ou à le voir deux de
tenir les deux les deux extrémités de la
situation dans laquelle il se trouve
vous dites r non je vois ces présidents
bon une fois de plus articulé quand même
la création d'un parti d' effectivement
je suis d'accord qu'il a créé
il est quasiment autogénérés il a quand
même ce souci d' assiettes et si vite
j'en reviens toujours à mon côté bifaces
rocard rocard et cheminement mais
revenons quand même à ce que disait
alain badiou le choix cet important
problème insoluble et philosophes sont
là pour dire que les problèmes sont
insolubles heureusement mais est ainsi
les pauses bien mais je pense que quand
même d'accrocher regarde de près son
pari et moi je dis ça va se jouer dans
les quatre cinq mois il le sait très
bien
c'est la capacité de faire bouger
l'allemagne sur certaines lignes
concernant le devenir européen
voilà moi c'est il ya deux lignes rouges
vous savez sur le droit du travail
si ceci va trop loin et que la ligne
rouge a cassé le dt il n'a pas ça ira
mal et de les sur l'europe il faut rouge
et là on fait de la politique il faut
qu'il a il faut alors pour aller un
petit peu plus loin je vous conseille
emmanuel macron révolution c'est notre
combat pour la france est sorti chez xo
éditions en 2016 donc c'est un livre
programmatique dont qui date d'il ya
quelques mois macron par macron
excellent un donc aux éditions de l'aube
donc c'est un recueil de plusieurs
échanges avec les camps d'entraînement
que nourrit alors anne fulda emmanuel
macron un jeune homme si parfait le vrai
visage du nouveau président qui est
sorti chez plon il y à quelques temps
emmanuel macron les coulisses d'une
victoire de françois-xavier bourmaud
c'est à l'archipel
soizic mnr et alexandre duyck on signale
irrésistible ascension les dessous d'une
présidentielle insensé chez flammarion
marc endeweld enfin l'ambigu monsieur
macron enquête sur un ministre qui
dérange c'est toujours chez flammarion
enfin je voulais vous préciser la
fabrique de l'histoire d'emmanuel
laurentin excellente émission de nos
confrères de france culture emmanuel
macron étaient invités le 9 mars dernier
l'imaginaire historique des manuels
macro une bonne manière de prolonger
messieurs merci pour ce dialogue qui
nous a enrichis tout de suite c'est
votre second film comment transmettre la
mémoire de l'horreur c'est la question
que se pose chaque jour les
conservateurs et des guides d'achat
chips en pologne le camp d'extermination
devenu musée il ya 70 ans accueille des
millions de visiteurs chaque année à
auschwitz museum c'est un film de
sébastien mort à tout à l'heure